Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and during my
Arrow Deathstroke video I asked you all to
submit questions about Isabel, Slade’s Plans
and the rest of the season.
I picked 10 with one bonus question.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do Q&A videos for all my favorite things
like Game Of Thrones, Doctor Who and anything
else that’s worth doubling down on.
Feel free to leave me suggestions for other
bonus videos for Arrow in the comments below.
We’ve only got a few more episodes left
before the finale.
On to questions.
Let’s talk our way through the WTF fest
that was Deathstroke.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode.
Here we go, Question 1 - Slade Wilson Asks
There were some new images of Summer Glau
dressed in a costume like Slade’s do you
think she’s secretly Rose Wilson, or will
she just be Isabel dressed as Ravager.
Very good question, this was actually something
really big that happened early Thursday morning.
The images look legit and essentially show
her as Ravager.
Based on the information we have right now
we can’t say she’s Rose, but we can call
her Ravager.
They might just be messing with the character
a little.
Arrow has been pretty faithful to the comics,
like when Billy Wintergreen wore the Deathstroke
mask, they didn’t call him Deathstroke.
They waited and gave that to Slade Wilson.
So if it looks like Ravager and fights like
Ravager, it probably is Ravager.
But Isabel Rochev in the comics had this history
with Oliver’s Father and there’s a theory
she was that woman you see off screen in season
1, with the Red Shoes.
That character was also involved in a plot
to use Queen Industries to make a super soldier
army.
So until the show presents us with more information
lets say she’s Isabel Ravager, not Rose
Wilson Ravager.
The mystery is still what her history with
Slade is and how they started working together.
Question 2 - McLovin asks Do you think that
the suicide squad, merlyn, and team arrow
will have to team up to beat team Deathstroke?
I definitely think the Suicide Squad will
be involved after that last scene with Amanda
Waller in the suicide squad episode.
As for Merlyn, John Barrowman just tweeted
that he was back in Vancouver for filming.
He didn’t confirm Arrow, but they’re filming
the finale.
So it seems like he won’t be back till Episode
23.
Merlyn is really only in it for Thea, so the
only way Merlyn would fight with them is if
it was to defend her.
So Slade and his army will have to put her
under the knife.
We know the super soldier army will be going
crazy all over the city in episode 22 Streets
of Fire.
Based on this image.
So it’s possible that something could happen
to Thea that would compel Merlyn to help Oliver.
I really want to see this happen.
I love John Barrowman and I love it when bitter
enemies are forced to work together.
It makes for amazing storytelling.
Question 3 - Tim asks Do you think Roy will
have his own Dark Tinkerbell, and who could
it be?
2.
Do you think Thea might become Artemis?
3 Do you think that Slade's army of Super
Soldier's will all receive super powers equal
to Slade and Roy, or will the serum give them
adverse effects like the "the Big Bang" that
created Static Shock, and open the series
with Villains with different Powers or abilities?
Lots of questions, so I’ll try to keep my
answers short.
Roy’s Tinkerbell, would of course be an
evil Thea.
Thea as Artemis I think is further off.
I think the next big character shift we’ll
see is Laurel as Black Canary.
No idea if that will happen in season 3, it
all depends on whether Caity Lotz dies in
the finale.
She’s listed in the credits on the wiki
for Episode 22 Streets of Fire.
But we still don’t know anything about the
finale.
And as for Super Soldiers.
They’ll be just like Slade and Roy.
But Mirakuru just enhances your own natural
abilities.
So if the criminals weren’t good fighters
before, Mirakuru isn’t going to magically
turn them into ninjas.
Think of them as like a super strong infantry.
Slade will just shoot them at the city like
a shotgun.
Question 4 - Galaxy Ronin asks Do you think
Deathstroke is getting all of his funding
from H.I.V.E.?﻿
Yeah, the HIVE teaser was a pretty huge deal
in that Russia episode.
They were the ones that hired Deadshot to
kill Diggle’s brother.
Deadshot implied that it was because Diggle’s
brother was into something shady with HIVE,
but I think that plot might be something that
will factor into season 3.
Remember in one of my previous Q&As I listed
potential villains for season 3.
HIVE was one of them.
In the comics Slade Wilson’s former wife
was a founding member of HIVE, there’s also
Queen Bee.
But we haven’t learned anything new about
either of those characters recently.
So HIVE is still a mystery.
I would guess that Slade has ties to them.
He’s probably not running HIVE, but using
them the way Oliver uses ARGUS and the Suicide
Squad.
Question 5 - Courageous asks Do you think
Brother Blood might be Jericho?
I saw a lot of comments about this, mostly
because of the Isabel Ravager teaser, implying
that she might secretly be Rose Wilson.
But remember, Brother Blood’s real life
mother talked about him killing his real life
father when he was little.
So I think Slade is just using Blood as a
means to an end.
That final scene with them together made it
seem like Slade has been withholding a lot
of critical information from him.
So don’t be surprised if he throws Blood
to the wolves before the end.
Question 6 - Dragon Animations (no avatar)
asks Do you think Thea could become a villain?
In the real world of the show no I don’t
think so, but there’s always the possibility
that she could be Roy’s Evil Tinkerbell
like Shado is to Slade.
I want to see Thea get to participate in the
action at some point.
She is a big part of the story in episode
20.
Question 7 - Funkasaurus asks For Episode
20 Seeing Red do you think its going to be
a Flash crossover or about Roy as he gets
mad.
Initially when they announced the title I
thought they’d do a Flash crossover.
Before the decided to do a separate pilot
for The Flash, this was going to be a backdoor
pilot.
Like a total Flash episode.
But when that changed they decided to make
episode 19 a crossover with Killer Frost and
Vibe and we now know that Episode is all Roy.
He basically loses his shit and Team Arrow
has to deal with him.
He gets super violent and Sara wants to kill
him, remember she’s the same person that
wanted to suicide bomb Slade on the Island.
Oliver and Thea try to talk him down, but
he ends up hurting Thea and Oliver opens up
a can of whoop ass.
No idea how that conflict will play out, but
it’s all about them dealing with Roy after
he starts to go really really crazy like Slade.
Part of the conceit with Sara wanting to Kill
Roy is that she thinks he’s uncurable, she
thinks there’s no way to fix Mirakuru Madness.
I think the solution to the Roy problem is
going to be very important for how they deal
with Slade in the finale.
It seems like the only way to completely fix
Roy would be to counteract the effects of
the Mirakuru.
So maybe they’ll try to find some way to
get it out of his system or some mirakuru
grade anti-rage pills.
Question 8 - Trey Splawn (no avatar) asks
Do you think that Amanda Waller is going to
use Roy as Arsenal in the Suicide Squad?
No, I think after they fix Roy so to speak,
he’ll continue to roll with Team Arrow.
Amanda Waller mostly just works with convicts
when it comes to the Suicide Squad.
Like full on super-villains.
She might get involved when they try to deal
with roid rage roy, say that three times fast.
Question 9 - Steven KC asks How about when
Felicity told Oliver to "Go get Thea, and
kill Slade" line?
I actually think this was really important.
It really defines Felicity’s relationship
with Oliver.
She’s his lightning rod, flash joke rimshot.
Oliver is supposed to be the leader, everyone
looks to him for guidance.
So he has to have someone that can provide
him with some clarity.
And that’s Felicity.
So you could say that family aside, Felicity
is the most important member on team Arrow.
Because she keeps Oliver from going crazy.
Question 10 - Ryan asks Based on the preview
for episode 19, do you think team arrow will
break into Star Labs to get some type of technology
to use against Slade?﻿ (Flash new 52 power
generator)
Yes, based on the clip it looks like Sara
comes up with the plan to “borrow” something
from Star Labs.
And that’s how the Flash characters get
involved.
It’s Daniel Panabaker as Caitlin Snow and
Cisco Ramon, two researchers working at Star
Labs.
In the timeline, this is all happening in
real time, so it’s been a couple months
since the Particle Accelerator exploded and
gave Barry Allen his powers.
We don’t know if or when Snow will become
Killer Frost or Cisco will become Vibe.
It would be awesome if it happens in the episode.
But as quickly as the story moves, I feel
like they’re going to save that kind of
stuff for the actual Flash TV Show whenever
it comes.
In the clip Cisco is firing a big weapon,
so that could be something Oliver and Sara
are trying to steal, but Star Labs is full
of neat super hero tech.
anb one last Bonus Question - James Thomas
asks Do you think the death of a character
is what will bring team Arrow back together?﻿
You’re talking about Agent Coulson and the
Avengers.
There have been a lot of events recently that
suggest that might happen.
Like suicide bomber Sara, Laurel Black Canary
teases, Moira and Detective Lance talking
about not being able to take the pain of losing
people.
Something tells me that Team Arrow will be
fixed again before the finale.
I don’t think they’ll do a straight up
copy of what happened in Avengers, but I do
think someone will die in one of those last
two episodes.
It just feels like the plot is building to
that kind of a moment.
Everyone be sure to let me know who you think
is going to die.
And thanks so much for submitting questions,
I always love doing Q&A videos.
I’m actually working on something special
for Game of Thrones that if it works, I’ll
start doing it for other big shows like Arrow.
Next week is a break, so I’ll be doing a
bonus Arrow video, be sure to subscribe to
get it and leave me suggestions for what to
talk about.
In the meantime check out my top 10 wtf moments
from the episode here and click here for my
Winter Soldier Review.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!